[Музика]
привіт, хлопці, настав час для англійської
урок мене звати Наталія лече кон
давайте почнемо сьогодні, ми маємо останній
урок по темі і продовжуємо
Говорячи про бібліотеки, я запрошую вас
до бібліотеки і давайте послухаємо
діалог, який я створив для вас
ти готовий давайте почнемо привіт як я можу
допомогти тобі
доброго ранку, я тут вперше
учень восьмого класу і ми
розповідали про публічні бібліотеки в школі
тому я вирішив бути молодим
Мені дуже приємно це чути
мене звати Ольга а як тебе
ім'я приємно познайомитися Ольга мене звати
Наталя теж рада познайомитись
тож Ольга, я можу задати тобі питання що
стало приводом для публічного обговорення
бібліотеки так, впевнені, що це була частина нашої
модуль ми говорили про матеріали для читання
різні види літератури та книг
і, звичайно, ми говорили про бібліотеки
ага, я так бачу, коли був студентом
була моєю улюбленою темою, і тому я
став бібліотекарем власне сказати, як зробив
ви знайдете уроки літератури вони
були фантастичними, і я багато чому навчився
насправді я отримав багато цікавого
факти та інформація, що добре зроблено
ви, звичайно, обговорюєте різні журнали
ми говорили про різні книги, хм, нехай
Я розповім вам про жанри, які я пам'ятаю
тому науково-фантастичні книги
книги любовні оповідання детективи
пригодницькі книги хм фантастика
фантастичні романи ми можемо назвати їх як
це класичні романи, а також жахи
історії
які домашні книги біографії також і
що було твоїм улюбленим я люблю читати
і вони читають різні книжки так
мабуть, я б пішов на любовні книги
моя улюблена я бачу
можу я запитати, що кожен заперечує, що це фантастика
роман під назвою «Золотий компас».
Філіп Пулман, це цікаво і
що це про дівчину, яка
живе в чужому всесвіті це добре
о, так, я не можу це відкласти
Я люблю читати фантастичні романи, які у мене є
яскрава уява, і це мені допомагає
зображувати епізоди чи події
Приклад, на якому ми вивчали вірш
школи і через картини і
жести, це допомогло мені запам’ятати це
з першого разу вау це звучить
фантастично я це чую, ви можете так дозволити
Спочатку я розповім тобі вірш, а потім я
скаже вам жестами, добре так
давайте послухаємо
Я так схвильований, давайте зробимо це
коробка, повна шоколаду hip-hip-hooray a
коробка, повна шоколаду, моя ціна сьогодні
трикутник прямокутник кола і квадрат
від коробки до мого животика цукерок
yummy yummy, тому давайте зробимо це ще раз
жести добре, давайте зробимо це ще раз
подивись на мене і повтори повну коробку
шоколад hip-hip your'e коробка повна
шоколад
це моя ціна сьогодні трикутник прямокутник
коло і квадрат від коробки до моєї
цукерки на животику смачно смачно ось
дивовижний
дозвольте мені спробувати, щоб ви мене слухали добре
ну давай наповнюємо повітряну коробку
з шоколаду
хіп-хіп-ура коробка, повна шоколаду
це моя ціна сьогодні трикутник прямокутник
коло і квадрат від коробки до моєї
животик шоколадні цукерки yummy yummy
це фантастично Браво, схоже на тебе
були дуже цікаві уроки саме у мене
їм подобається вся інформація
вибір вчителя для своїх уроків
дуже сучасний, наприклад ми обговорюємо таке
книги як Гаррі Поттер Маленькі жінки
Зоряні війни Шерлок Холмс Елізабет
Королева Єлизавета Королева
цікавий
так
«Королева Єлизавета» — біографічний роман
він написаний Саллі Беделл Сміт
і це історія про світ
відома Мона, але ви, напевно, знаєте це
все добре завжди цікаво почути
на думку читачів так Ольга що б
ти любиш читати, коли закінчиш
Золотий компас, про який я думав
Гаррі Поттер я прочитав усі книги
український і тепер я думаю, що я готовий
Англійська фантастичний вибір нашого репортера
книги наповнені цікавою лексикою
Ви можете сказати, що з нашим учителем ми вчимося a
багато цікавих фраз ой тримайся я
запишу їх добре, я готовий
добре, давайте, номер один — помахати а
чарівна паличка добре номер два, щоб працювати як
магія
добре номер три, щоб витягнути кролика
Капелюха фантастичний номер чотири
жаба в одному горлі всього за секунду
так номер п'ять випусти кота з
сумка
Гаразд номер шість робити замки в
повітря' добре сім багато місяців тому я готовий
і номер вісім власних смаків
Метсон добре, я готовий
чи все гаразд, можна перевірити
будь ласка, дайте мені побачити мм-хм чотири п'ять шість
насправді у вас є пара помилок
тут це виглядає як номер три чотири
п'ять і шість неправильні
тож давайте виправимо помилки, ну добре
то скажіть мені, які є правильні підвищення
[Музика]
тож номер три — витягнути кролика
полювання
добре, я виправив це число чотири на
мати жабу в одному горлі ага добре я
щойно зустрів, я переплутав їх, вибачте номер
п'ять
випусти кота з мішка ах це з
сумка не з капелюхів ладно і
номер шість для створення повітряних замків
Гаразд
тепер я знаю, як будувати повітряні замки
велике дякую, з моєю радістю
у вас є книги про Гаррі Поттера, дозвольте мені
перевірте, хм, у нас є Гаррі Поттер і
проклята дитина
тобі це подобається о так, це моє
улюблена частина
Я піду з цим, що мені потрібно зробити
це легко
можу попросити ваше посвідчення особи, яке мені потрібно
підтвердити свою адресу
о так, ось це, дякую
добре, зараз потрібно просто поставити
Ваш підпис тут добре ідеальний, так що
книга твоя в порядку, дуже дякую
протягом двох тижнів, якщо ви збираєтеся запізнитися
з потрібним періодом позики
приходьте і забронюйте його знову є
плата за несвоєчасне повернення товарів і за
резервування предметів, які надаються в позику
іншого позичальника, я думаю, що я в порядку
два тижні дякую дуже дякую
дуже за цікаву розмову
книга чудова, дуже дякую
було чудово поговорити з вами, бачите, є
незабаром гарного дня Ольго і насолоджуйся ним
у вашій книзі до побачення, до побачення
добре, хлопці, вам сподобався діалог
ми переглянули багато інформації, що
ми дізналися під час цього модуля, тому ми
переглянуті різні жанри, ви пам'ятаєте
які вони були науковою науковою літературою
фантастика книги любовні книги кримінал
трилери пригодницькі історії що ще
книги біографії фентезі книги хмм що
інакше ви пам'ятаєте детективи
також правильно
[Музика]
тому ми також переглянули корисні фрази з
мої улюблені книги про Гаррі Поттера
багато багато місяців тому
і витягніть кролика з мішка ці
мої улюблені фрази, а твої
улюблені фрази ми також переглядаємо мої
улюблений вірш про шоколад, який я люблю
шоколад це моя улюблена їжа
Я хотів би їсти шоколад кожен
один день з ранку до вечора так
хлопці, настав час попрацювати
як ти писати диктант зараз ти
можна побачити визначення слів на
екран, тому візьміть блокнот і
швидко запиши слова, які я тобі даю
одна хвилина, щоб записати їх
[Музика]
тож давайте перевіримо разом, тепер ви можете побачити
правильні відповіді на екрані, щоб ви
можете перевірити самі
[Музика]
і якщо у вас немає помилок, ви можете дати
собі десять балів говорять, що ми повинні
закінчіть тему і я сподіваюся, що ви
насолоджуйтеся уроком літератури
різні дієслова різних жанрів і
починаючи з наступного уроку ми
збираюся говорити про школу та освіту
побачимось наступного разу, насолоджуйся днем ​​до побачення
[Музика]
ти